We have an absolutely stunning turn of events
today.
A veritable treasure trove of impeachment
related documents have been released by the
house intelligence committee and they include
among them text messages, exposing that Donald
Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, had his now
indicted henchman putting ambassador Marie
Evanovich under physical surveillance outside
and around the embassy in Ukraine.
Check out some of these examples.
These are texts, text messages between Robert
Hyde, a landscaper turned lobbyist who has
donated a bunch of money to Trump and is running
for some position in Connecticut, although
we expect that that will be wrapping up pretty
soon.
He was once arrested at Donald Trump's Mar-a-Lago
resort and brought to a medical facility for
a psych eval.
He seems to have been coordinating with Lev
Parness, one of Rudy Giuliani's henchmen,
uh, around physical surveillance of ambassador
Maria Bonovitch.
I'm still trying to sort it all out.
Check out some of these text messages.
This is a Robert Heide texting Lev Parness
that address I sent you checks out.
It's next to the embassy.
They are willing to help.
If we, you would like a price suggesting that
he's talking to people near the embassy who
for a price can do whatever it is Rudy wants
done to the ambassador.
Later texting updates.
She will not be moved.
Special security unit, upgraded force on the
compound.
People are already aware of the situation.
My contacts are asking what is the next step
because they cannot keep going to check.
People will start asking questions.
Another one makes it seem as though they are
continuing to track you.
Von of itches realtime movements quote, she's
next to the embassy, not in the embassy.
Private security been there since Thursday.
There's more.
They will let me know when she's on the move
and they'll let me know when she's on the
move.
Perfect.
I mean where if they can find out correcting
that last text message.
So we've confirmed that when the state department
said there were threats to Marie Ivana, which
is security, they were right.
She was being followed around.
It just so happens it was Donald Trump's people
through his lawyer and his lawyers, henchmen
that were following around.
Marie, Ivana, bitch.
There are assertions that they had a plan
for some kind of physical violence, although
those are merely assertions at this point
in time, it almost seems like Rudy Giuliani
should have been arrested or at minimum at
this point forced to come in to answer questions
about this and undoubtedly should be part
of the upcoming Senate impeachment trial and
this is just one piece of what they have.
There is reportedly audio.
There is reportedly video that is available
with further incriminating evidence regarding
what was going on with Maria Bonovitch, which
Republicans want to keep all of this stuff
out of the upcoming Senate impeachment trial.
Of course, it should all be in the Senate
impeachment trial and we will see ultimately
what happens because the United States is
being run like the mob.
Donald Trump is president.
He wants to bribe and extort Ukraine into
publicly smearing Joe Biden, but there's problems.
So Donald Trump says, let's fix those problems.
He gets Rudy Giuliani, his personal attorney,
who has no government role, not confirmed
by the Senate, not elected to anything.
He gets Rudy Giuliani to do the dirty work.
Rudy Giuliani then says, okay, let's hire
some henchmen.
He brings in Lev Parness and Igor Fruman and
says, Maria Bonovitch is a problem.
Rudy has publicly admitted that he worked
to get Maria Bonovitch out of the way.
That's his phrase.
Phrasiology not mine.
So love partner says, I know what to do.
Let's get physical surveillance put on Maria
Bonovitch like the mob through this guy Robert
Hyde, who has an insane history and they are
tracking her.
They're following her around.
They seemingly are plotting something not
okay to do to an ambassador.
We can say that with certitude at this point,
even if we don't have more details, the mob
is in the white house.
They're in the white, and they are, uh, so
far going unpunished.
Trump impeached in the house, but of course
likely to be acquitted in the Senate.
So hopefully one of the things we'll know
by tomorrow or maybe by Friday is what of
all of this treasure trove of information
will be part of the impeachment trial in the
Senate, which witnesses will be subpoenaed
to come in.
We want to hear from John Bolton.
We should hear from Rudy Giuliani, hopefully
love Parness, we'll be participating.
It seems he has the goods and is all of a
sudden more than willing to actually spill
them.
This is getting insane and we're going to
have a followup coverage of this on our Instagram
account.
If you are on Instagram, follow the David
[inaudible].
How can show at David Pakman show?
And while you're there, follow me at David
dot [